sometimes
games bring out the worst in people i am
sure
we have all experienced toxic behavior
before perhaps we've even been the toxic
ones ourselves sometimes
and pro players are no different it's
easy to point out toxic behavior
but it always feels good to highlight
the players who redeem themselves when
everyone thought they were completely
irredeemable sometimes in life the
villains live long
enough to see themselves become the
heroes these are the top 10
toxic redemption stories
talent meets toxicity at our number 10
with
simple i think you're stupid you just
stupid player that's why you don't know
i think you don't understand what to do
and how to help your teammate
i think you think only about your game
ironically things have never been
simple when it comes to this cs go
superstar on the one hand he will go
down in history as one of the most
talented players to ever touch the game
simple i swear if you do anything
ridiculous now i am going to oh oh
there it is just ridiculous on the other
hand
his rise to the top was mired with
accusations of toxicity
from those around him did you pick cash
yeah do we do it we want to win man
want to win we can win on another map
five we should play second battle
second map cash oh my god
but simple's worst moments are from
early in his career and
since then he's clearly grown as a
person and has learned to appreciate
not deprecate those around him only two
weeks and we destroyed everyone sorry
teams
i'm just kidding just that's great
moment thanks perfecto boomwich and
blade for coming in this team thanks to
our
psychologists as well
cussing into our number nine spot we
have the one and only crimsex
in guide button few dude
oh my [ __ ] [ __ ] dude in call of
duty
nobody can deny krimsix's skill there's
been times where he made other pros look
straight up silly up to gaming just
completely
42 kills for crimson six ben 42
that's uh this is insane he's on an
eight kill streak nine kill streak now
man
is pretty good at cut man but crim has
always balanced his incredible skill
with incredible toxicity yeah are you an
ar are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] they're sorry
like [ __ ] dude they pulled out two bars
dude
you can't teach someone to be that
[ __ ] bad girl
my god even crims teammates weren't
spared from his rage
just ask skump if we played a good
[ __ ] team we get
punished for this no i was trying to say
this four
times on the map and you guys are just
bullshitting these days krim continues
to
dominate the game after seven years at
the top but it seems he may
finally be starting to mellow and be
more graceful in his victories
listen i'm i've never been a sore winner
i've been a sore winner one time
in my whole career and facento aqua
nagafan and someone else i apologize for
being like that
and listen i'm not gonna be like them
i'm not gonna talk trash
at number eight we have mr 150k
himself it's sinatra there's been times
where he's been seen as
one of the best in overwatch and they
finally
break through here
yeah another grab from sinatra and are
you kidding me
and there's definitely been times that
he's been seen as one of the most
toxic that's a garbage ass suck i hate
you
yeah hydration is garbage whoa wait a
minute wait that's it i
i said that out loud i might get banned
early in his career sinatra struggled
with toxicity
but when he chilled out a little and
cooled off the aggro comms
success finally came for the young
prodigy
now i have to ask you got the overwatch
league mvp
now i get the overwatch world cup mvp
are you the best player in the world
um yeah yes there you have it
a lot of people put this in-game
improvement down to his
improved mentality and sinatra would be
the first to agree
uh i i gotta give it to my coaching
staff uh krusty junkbug 9k they really
helped me
just grow as a player an individual a
teammate and a leader
um so i'm just really grateful for them
at number seven we have idra idra is a
veteran of the starcraft 2 and brood war
scene who
in the past was never too shy about
speaking his mind
unfortunately though what was on his
mind was usually
pretty toxic what do you think about
cruncher and how do you think this match
is gonna go
i'm playing really bad but it's more
than enough to beat him
dong ragu and mma are very good
uh troy is bad
but idris most famous toxic moment was
the time he appeared to ragequit a
very winnable game at mlg columbus 2011.
streaming forward with circling's mutas
everything is overrunning the sports by
mma
wait what
with enough time though every volcano
cools down
itra has since reflected on his past and
found more healthy ways of venting that
famous anger of his and now i don't know
i was kind of an angry competitor so i
don't know how healthy it is
so i kind of don't compete anymore i
think weightlifting kind of filled that
role for me
but no the starcraft was just a way to
beat people
and
it ain't easy being arteezy at number
six
when he's playing at his best rtz is
certified
insane at doterra go baby's going
forward he's going for rtz but he
doesn't have the damage no
arteezy pumps it out too much he gets
the ultra kelly gets the rampage
it's not over yet though he's known for
his ruthless
aggression in game but that aggression
has spilled out of the game too
shut the [ __ ] up
at times even something as small as a
tip
when he's losing has been known to make
him lay
into someone so what a tip parties for
me i'll join in on the fun
dude you set me up man but arteezy
doesn't think he's toxic
he believes that positivity is the key
to success he believes in the power of
p m a i figured out
that if i'm mean to my team and rude to
my team we usually lose
so i'm like a positive guy you know i
make them play better
you know just positive vibes pma
positive mental attitude
it's the team hopping jungler at number
five
the one and only dardoch dardoch was
once heralded as
the most promising jungler in the lcs
and he
certainly lived up to the hype
[Music]
the arctic assault prediction the reason
dialogue has bounced between
seven different teams in five years is
his history of
conflict with those around him even
coaches weren't safe from the crossfire
i disappear 100 i think it's absolutely
[ __ ] everything coming out of his
mouth came from the ass for us you can't
take criticism at all
i take criticism just fine when it's
actual criticism team liquid's breaking
point documentary
shed a light on dardoch's behavior both
in and
out of game his toxicity sometimes took
the form of borderline
trolling on stage this can do baron or
some [ __ ] dude
i go to the next game already
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] pointless what
the hell i just want to play the next
one
however unlike some of the other entries
on our list
dardoch has acknowledged his behavior
and shown signs of changing it
he's managed to settle down with
dignitas for over a year at this point
and it may still save his legacy yet
sorry to everybody that i've
caused emotional pain to or mental
strain um sorry for making
you know so many coaches stressed about
me and what teams can do the next day in
practice because i can't act right
at number four we have doki the most
toxic
player in rainbow six siege i mean
dining
neverland
that was the moment in october 2019 that
doki found out that ubisoft had banned
him
in definitely from siege he also got
banned by esl
from all of their tournaments for the
next six months
due to severe toxicity at first doki was
just as confused as everyone else he had
to watch from the sidelines as his
team navi won the pro league season 10
finals
timer's so dangerously low he has to
kill both of them so
very quickly but it doesn't matter
no v they did not come to participate
they came to take over europe has
birthed
two titans in one year but before that
happened
doki shared what transpired behind the
scenes
on pengu's stream and there's been no
sign of misdemeanors since
in my opinion i should not be punished
something i did a while ago
not now it's like like i don't know what
it is but they said it's like three
years ago i was like okay
well thanks thank you i'm a completely
different person
there we've got an og
at number three now with i will dominate
these days
dom is known in the league community as
a content creator who does
not hold back on his opinions it's the
most uploaded comment of the entire time
this one is a scene dude you're not c9
dude you're just a [ __ ] random you're
a piss random with a piss random opinion
dom was the first lcs player to ever hit
challenger his talent was undeniable but
his negative behavior
eventually landed him with a one-year
ban from the lcs
for toxicity after i got banned i was
kind of at a crossroads at that point
should i continue playing professionally
or whether to just like
call it quits there and just continue
where my life was
dom eventually returned to the lcs
before retiring in 2016
and became a streamer where his angry
moments became
far more visible it's okay dom
we all had these games just move on from
it
hope you have most of you guys don't
because most of you guys are liking
silver
well you are playing like a silver so i
thought i could relate
kappa i mean i'm playing fine but you're
just like a [ __ ] hater
so you're just gonna find like flaws no
matter what don continued to divide
people's opinions as he grew his stream
in july 2020 things came to a head when
dom was banned from the league of
legends partner program for
toxicity although this looked like a
slide back to his old ways
dom's emotional reaction is perhaps a
sign that he has
no intention of any further bans
i did not want to be upset about this
it's just like
really hard for me and then like seeing
you guys sad
about like this decision all right it's
actually like
that's the part that actually like hurts
the most because it feels like i let you
guys down i just don't know like
why this happened you know like i really
wish i knew
what caused them to make this decision
what's a king to a god what's a god to
an angry smash player at the number two
spot
it's leffen now positioning is
yeah very
[Applause]
of course every story needs a villain
and for many years
leffen filled that role in smash bros he
was the dark horse who
regularly took sets off the five gods of
the game
that's it that's it and levitt takes it
over mewtwo king of three stalker
dreamland
leffen has made history but
any conversation about leffen's
abilities will eventually turn
to some of his more controversial moves
it wasn't just his opponents and the
viewers either
leffen was banned from european
tournaments in 2013
for toxicity that included flaming new
players and
bullying time can change a person though
and his toxic label has faded over the
years
and these days the smash scene views him
as a community
leader i do definitely agree that i
acted like a
jerk and that i need to do much like
i need to be much much better going
forward is what i realized
and who else could it be at the number
one spot other than tyler1
he became one of the most famous league
streamers for three reasons
playing draven
verbally abusing his teammates why are
you going
in and running it down mid if he didn't
get his way
hey some thought he was a menace to the
game
others thought he was the most
entertaining league streamer
period riot weren't about to have a
toxic poster boy though
and slap tyler with a permaban across
all present and future accounts i'm
gonna miss you guys
i'm gonna miss you guys i am
it's been fun i've had a fun uh you know
a fun time streaming with you boys i
have
it's been fun tyler became a variety
streamer and although his games changed
his behavior certainly didn't
tyler was eventually unbanned and made
his peace with riot
some have since said that his toxicity
was all an act
that tyler plays up to the camera and
maybe that's true
but even if it wasn't real tyler has
gone from toxic
to hilarious
and i'm wearing a different shirt for
the outro i hope you all enjoy that guys
i find the relationship between toxicity
and skill quite interesting sometimes
some of the most highly skilled people
in the world can also be quite toxic at
games what is that all about
i don't know maybe you guys have the
answers let me know in the comments also
let me know what video you want to see
next on the channel subscribe if you
haven't done so already and i will see
you all
in the next one i'm not toxic i
definitely used to be
i've definitely been chat restricted
it's one of those weird things because
they give you like five messages to say
when you're chat restricted
but i knew i would get angry when i was
in that go for that really toxic period
so i would just use up all five messages
straight away
i would just say like a b c d e or i go
one three four five or just like type
something use up all five
so i was i basically muted myself